hey welcome to the monitor as always I
am Peter Reuben senior editor at wired
in this week what do we have we have a
television show that somehow manages to
not make me cringe we have a new comic
book that you should catch up on but
first we have the way I'm going to be
spending my Christmas Day and that is
seeing a young woman named Jane Guan
chained django unchained from Quentin
Tarantino is hitting theaters next
Tuesday and yeah that's a few days from
now and if the Mayan apocalypse manages
to not happen we'll all be there but
this is the thing I am still looking
forward to perhaps most of anything this
year it is the story of course of a man
named Jango played by Jamie Foxx a slave
in the antebellum South who is freed by
a bounty hunter and trained in the art
of bounty hunting why to go rescue his
wife from an evil evil slave owner named
in Colonel candle or candy candle candle
candle Leo DiCaprio plays them that's
all we need to know anyway huge ensemble
cast as befits a clinton tarantino
production you've got Kerry Washington
you've got Christoph vaults who we all
loved in inglourious basterds we have uh
Samuel Jackson of course it's far and
wide uh I kind of like this this revenge
kick that he's been on recently and by
recently I mean over the past few movies
inglourious basterds was an absolute joy
and I have been waiting for Jengo
Unchained since the day that we thought
Chris Tucker would be playing django but
it is not chris tucker it is Jamie Foxx
but it is still going to be a lot of fun
it opens on Tuesday I suggest you check
it out but not on my theater and don't
beat in food and being all loud about it
because I want to enjoy this in silence
let's talk about comic books there is a
comic book out this week that is
actually the the third and a four-issue
series but it made me realize I haven't
spoken about this yet and I would very
much like to because I would very much
like you to discover and read this book
it is called multiple warheads it's by a
guy named brandon graham a youngish
writer illustrator based in Vancouver
now he wrote a one-off multiple warhead
book for Oni Press a while back but this
he has developed those characters in the
setting into a four-issue miniseries as
being published an image it is the story
of a
young in love couple sex occur and
Nikoli Nikoli is a werewolf and they are
fleeing their hometown in Russia but not
any Russia we would recognize it as a
sci-fi futuristic Russia and they are
they've gone for a road trip they packed
up they had to vacate their city and now
they are off to parts unknown now what's
so fantastic about this is there is this
a sense of whimsy that that pervades the
book Brandon Graham is really into puns
and wordplay and he fills his panels
with it this is a book that rewards
close reading like there is the story
that goes through but it's almost
secondary to the attention that he pays
to the denizens of this world every
character has these little one-off punny
one-liners I mean I am unabashedly a pun
nerd so I'm really getting off on this
book if you don't groan at every pun you
here and even actually even if you do
run it every pun you hear multiple
warheads might just be an undiscovered
joy for you this holiday season so check
that out multiple warheads three is out
this week but you can go back and read 1
and 2 which I would recommend don't
worry about the one off you can just
jump in with one and start there let's
talk about television so there was a
show on fuse I know right a show on fuse
not just videos of lady gaga there was a
show on fuse called Billy on the street
it's kind of a pop-culture game show
that is really the the structure of it
but I usually hate shows that involve
pranking or otherwise victimizing
defenseless people who have no idea what
they're getting into they didn't sign up
for this etc I don't like that stuff but
Billy on the street manages to kind of
ride that line where I never cringe I
never feel like this person is taking
being taken advantage of Billy is kind
of masterful at being really abrasive
and hilarious and not alienating it's
it's a magical balancing act that he
pulls off they rerun season one all the
time they had some guest stars rashida
Jones have been on they've got some new
ones plan for this season it is if you
ever catch it a billy on the street'
marathon just sit down for one or two
episodes and I can almost guarantee that
you will be hooked like I have been in
recent times but I'm very excited about
the new season and it is back and I am
joy Singh so that is it for the monitor
this week now tomorrow is the last day
it is not only the winter solstice but
it is the last day of the current Mayan
calendar cycle so should the world end
you can disregard everything that I've
said today about Django Unchained and
Billy on the street but you should
probably read multiple warheads now just
in case we all shuffle off this mortal
coil but we will be back next week with
a very special holiday highlight reel
you can always email us at the monitor
we will see you next week but until then
inspirational catchphrase here
you